[Music]
are you Tracy
I'm gonna call you Conan enormocorp you
see black seats you're gonna call me see
black three gray okay I got street cred
now yeah thank you
I'll just be in here yeah that's fine
good farmer I know I know
next huh how are you you look great you
look you're terrific thank you and good
these days yes are you you know there's
so much to talk to you about so much
going on right now first of all a big
election coming up presidential election
how do you like Obama's chances I don't
know you know um
Mitt Romney's from Utah right yeah the
Mormons yes more they've got many wives
yes there you go
I'm going to responsible leadership for
lives I'm gonna before I say yeah you're
gonna vote for Romney
all right I'm I endorse imamova you know
cuz then you can have a lot of kids you
see if you just want to have a baby yeah
I want to make baby that's what I want
to do with my life
your aspiration is Rowdy you're my baby
that's so how are we doing the same time
oh my god that's awesome
so okay you're gonna want little karate
and make baby so I might go it Obama
because he's doing a great job with the
economics we need money right now man
okay it's getting bad out do you know
the rock is wrestling again
[Applause]
it's wrestling again that's terrible rah
that's awful
what about okay what about Obama do you
think I don't know a bunch of that which
Mountain money do you think he made that
much money on you it smell out of my
morning me very bad ass do you have a
spam yeah you see I am better good you
star right all right cooking for a
different way okay I like to fry up spam
I like spam yeah that's not bad is good
you gotta save your Universal key your
spam key yeah yeah it opens all the spam
cans hey you're talking to see black I
know
I am legend do you
that could really happen you know you
didn't get there he my under saw his
basket all man and yeah you gave good
$15 fit
yeah $15 to girl but our patient I am
now I'm curious
some people think it's gonna help Obama
that you know he killed Osama bin Laden
we're I think you care he's a gangbanger
if you form them you assassinate for
dictators you bang him he should get a
tan drop right here
Obama should get a teardrop tattoo he's
have a 20 year old from New Orleans
tattoo it in really well any other
tattoos he should give my all Michele
across his neck right here like NBA
players like NBA players from the Knicks
huh how you feel about the next year
that's your team right they're not in
the playoffs it yeah my team what
they're gonna be all right you know I've
got called the garden and we gonna fix
things but I just bought a franchise
myself like you you bought a franchise
what Magic Johnson Roger Dodgers I
bought the Milwaukee Brewers you bought
the Milwaukee Brewers well I just bought
the concession stands with he's so frank
[Applause]
he's so Hebrew Frank's this he's just he
was so Hebrew front okay you suck Hebrew
friends in front of selling Hebrew God
you know that's great and I'm building a
stadium or I'm starting my own franchise
back baseball team and we got building
the stadium right behind Cabrini Green
in Chicago in Chicago yes Cabrini Green
witty film good times yeah just looking
out of the window watching the a swablu
[Laughter]
[Music]
no 1jj father got killed and floors a
damn damn that's gonna be the name of
the team day I'm damned when you cross a
jersey damn damn
we're gonna take a break take a break
chasing Morgan in a second